right Southwest Medical Hospice Care the
sponsors of this segment provide the
Right Care at the right time and with
the right companion
we're originally from New York both of
us we met each other there and we're
still together
uh 57 years ago
and we came here on a honeymoon
and we just loved it so much that we
said to each other you know we'd like to
come back here and live here one of
these days and
my gosh we did we really did well my mom
was a
diagnosed with
[Music]
to recommended that she
enrolled in hospice which we did and
they were just wonderful to us and they
helped us do a very difficult time
and so we are so blessed to be part of
that organization that company and and
we just love it really and actually I
think the thing that sparked this too
was she went to a meeting
where they were looking for volunteers
for hospice and she was so impressed by
the way that woman talked to know that
she was all excited when she came home
and you know I get involved with her
basically we've been doing uh office
type of help filling out envelopes and
mailing mailing things and putting
together packages and
uh
basically that type of stuff and then
even they tuck in program there the
talking program that's a wonderful
program that's where we call patients
every Thursday to see how if they need
any medical supplies or medicine for the
weekend
and even if they don't need anything
they're so happy to hear from us so we
tucked them in for the weekend there's
so many areas that you can volunteer
that we were not even aware of until we
joined the program and you do whatever
is comfortable for you you try different
things and if you're not comfortable
then you can try something else but they
want you to feel comfortable while
spending time with the family of course
and I like to do yoga and I knit
blankets for the patients that brings me
such Joy I get such a kick out of that I
I just started knitting and I I just
loved it and I just thought it would be
a great thing to give the patients to
make them happy and put a smile on their
face and so I just started knitting and
I brought it down to to Linda and she
loved she loved it and I make lap
blankets or full blankets and I just got
a closet full of them to bring them down
you know Southwest the hospice care is
really enlightened us into all the
things that can be done and ways to help
it kind of makes you appreciate that
we're all in the same boat
we're all going to pass on someday and
it's really wonderful to have the care
and the love that they give you in the
final days of your life
[Music]
once again we want to thank Southwest
Medical for sponsoring this segment for
more information on hospice care call
the number on your screen or visit
s-m-a-l-v.com Las Vegas now we will be
right